welcome to the presentation on radians
and degrees so y'all have probably
already reasonably familiar with the
concept of degrees I think in our angles
modules we actually drill you through a
bunch of problems I mean let's see I
mean you're probably familiar that a
angle like let me make sure okay
put an angle that a right angle is 90
degrees or half a right angle 45 degrees
then you're also probably familiar with
the concept that in a circle and it
that's my best attempt at a circle in a
circle there are 360 degrees so today
I'm going to introduce you to another
measure or unit for angles and this is
called a Radian so what is a Radian
so I'll start with a definition and I
think this might give you a little
intuition for why it's even called
radiant so by definition Irate let me
let me use the circle tool and actually
draw a nice circle okay so by definition
oh oh I'm still using the the Radian
tool the circle tool okay so this is
let's say this is a radius of length R a
Radian is the angle that subtends an arc
and all sub-10 means is if this is the
angle that this is and this is the arc
this angle subtends this arc and this
arc subtends this angle so a Radian one
Radian is the angle that subtends an arc
that's the length of the radius so the
length of this is also R and this angle
is one Radian I think that's messy let
me draw it in a bigger circle here you
go and I'm going to do this because I
always wondering why they do radians we
all know degrees and but but actually
when you think about it actually makes a
reasonable amount of sense so let me use
the line tool now I'll just as neatly as
possible so let's say that
that and let's say that this radius is
of length R and that this arc right here
is also of length R then this angle
let's call it theta is equal to one
Radian and now it makes sense that they
call it a radiant it's kind of like a
radius so let me ask you a question how
many radians are there in a circle well
if this is R what is the whole
circumference of a circle it's two pi
all right now you know that from the
basic geometry module so if there if the
Radian is the angle that subtends an arc
of R then the angle that subtends an arc
of two PI R is two pi radians so this
angle is two pi radians if you're still
confused think of it this way at an
angle of 2 pi radians so going all the
way around subtends an arc of 2 pi
radiuses radii i don't know how to say
the plural of radius
maybe it's radians I don't know well
let's do so so why am I going through
all of this mess and confusing you well
I just want to 1 give you an intuition
for why it's called a Radian and kind of
how it relates to a circle and then
given that there are two pi radians in a
circle we can now figure out a
relationship between radians and degrees
let me delete this so we said in a
circle there are two pi radians right
let's say two pi radians and how many
degrees are there in a circle if we went
around a whole circle how many degrees
well that's equal to 360 degrees so
there we have an equation that sets up a
conversion between radians and degrees
so one Radian is equal to 360 over 2 pi
degrees right I just divide both sides
by 2 pi which equals 180
over PI degrees similarly we could have
done the other way we could have divided
both sides by 360 and we could have said
one degree all right I'm just going to
divide both sides by 360 and I'm
flipping it one degree is equal to 2pi
over 360 radians radians which equals PI
over 180 radians so there we have a
conversion one Radian equals PI over one
one Radian equals 180 over PI degrees
and one degree equals PI over 180
radians and if you ever forget these and
it doesn't hurt to to memorize this but
if you ever forget it I always go back
to this that two pi radians is equal to
360 degrees or another way and it
actually makes the algebra or the the
algebraic is you could little simpler is
if you just think of a half circle a
half circle this angle is 180 degrees
right 180 degrees that's a degree sign I
could also write degrees out and that's
also equal to PI radians right PI
radians so pi radians equal 180 degrees
and we can get the same map one Radian
equals 180 over PI degrees or one degree
degree that's degree is equal to PI over
180 radians so let's do a couple
problems where you look at the intuition
for this so if I asked you 45 degrees
and to convert that into radians radians
well we know that one degree is PI over
180 radians right so 45 degrees 45
degrees is equal to 45 times pi over 180
radians and let's see 45 divided by 180
45 goes into 180 4 times
this equals pi over 4 radians 45 degrees
is equal to PI over 4 radians and just
keep in mind where these are just two
different units or two different ways of
measuring angles and the reason why I do
this is this is actually the
mathematical standard for measuring
angles although all most of us are more
familiar with degrees just from everyday
life let's do a couple of other examples
and just always remember this one Radian
equals 180 over PI degrees one degree
equals PI over 180 radians if you ever
get confused just write this out this is
what I do because I always I always
forget whether it's PI over 80 180 or
180 over PI so I just remember PI
radians is equal to 180 degrees let's do
another one so if I were to say pi PI
over 2 radians equals how many degrees
well I already forgot what I had just
written so I just remind myself that PI
radians is equal to 180 degrees so pi
Radian is equal to 180 degrees oh oh my
wife just got home so I'm just going to
have to leave the presentation like that
and I will continue it later I think you
might get the pour actually let me just
finish this problem and then I'll go to
attend to my wife but we know that PI
radians is equal to 180 degrees right so
one Radian is equal to 180 over
that's one Radian is equal to 180 over
PI degrees all right I just figure out
the formula again because I always
forget it so let's go back here so PI
over 2 radians is equal to PI over 2
times 180 over PI degrees and that
equals 90 degrees 90 degrees I'll do one
more example
so if I were to say let's say 30 degrees
30 let me write let marrakesh write 30
degrees once again I forgot the formula
so I just remember that pi radians is
equal to is equal to 180 degrees so 1
degree is equal to PI over 180 radians
right so 30 degrees is equal to 30 times
PI over 180 radians which equals let's
see 30 goes in 186 times that equals PI
over 6 radians hopefully you have a
sense of how to convert between degrees
and radians now and even why it's called
a Radian because it's very closely
related to a radius and you'll feel
comfortable when someone asks you to I
don't know
deal with radians as opposed to degrees
I'll see you the next presentation